I was watching something they had on BBC
News you're looking at one of the oldest
fragments of the Quran ever discovered
it's written on parchment most likely
made from sheep or goat skin and it's
been dated by experts as being more than
1300 years old
alhamdulillah
Serbian who's now Muslim who's inspiring
to be a Hafiz of the Quran and I opened
up the Quran
and literally it was like the third
verse it was like the third verse
ayat 46.
do not be afraid
[Applause]
and his final messages
[Music]
the theme show
s
we got a wonderful and amazing story
with you
Marco here on the D show how you doing
Marco from the lamb doing good your
story how we met is very interesting
yeah I'm going to start it off and you
kick it off right we're at the at the
Masjid the mosque and you approached me
and then you were telling me how you
actually came to Islam and then you
mentioned the dean show you watch
someone you're on a journey seeking
purpose of life and you came across a
Dean show and it kind of did it for you
and then here we are did it did I give
you a condensed version yeah that was
pretty good
um yeah it was kind of crazy because I
was watching like a lot of different
videos and stuff and I came across your
videos it was like uh two or three weeks
after I converted
um I went to the Masjid for Juma and
then I seen you there and I was like
this guy looks a little familiar I was
like where do I know him from and I was
telling my friend I was like he looks so
familiar I just can't quite put my
finger on it and he was like oh I think
that they're they're having some uh
fundraising or something for uh the dean
show and I don't know and I was like oh
yeah I used to watch a lot of your
videos yeah you're trying to get the
property yeah
foreign
[Music]
bless your efforts Eddie
how you doing brother
all right so you can see we're getting
to work and we need your support so go
ahead and help us to get this where it's
Top Notch inshallah so yeah it was
pretty crazy yeah that was amazing right
there and what what stood out was your
story uh because you come from a Serbian
the background is from where my parents
are from from Bosnian they got Serbia
Croatia and that's kind of like almost
like the unforgivable sin yeah right
yeah people who think like okay if I'm
born Serbian if I'm born Croatian I die
that's like a religion yeah but uh you
just proved it wrong right here right
now yeah yeah so tell us uh what led to
that what led to you actually
making a decision that you're going to
even investigate look into Islam what
made you even at such a young age to
even contemplate thinking about like
purpose of life many people shut that
off yeah
you know that's something where you know
when Allah says in the Quran that he's
the best of all planners that's like
spot on because I had no real intention
to look into Islam I really didn't care
I'll be honest like to me it was just
like I'm Christian Orthodox I'm going to
practice it I love it I'll die is it
whatever you know
but I randomly like met a group of
Muslims
and to be honest I really didn't even
know they were Muslim at first it was
just like we were all friends and
hanging out and talking chatting it up
and they like slowly started giving me a
little bit of Doubt like just here like
you know one thing a day you know just
hey you know we believe in Jesus right
like you know small things like this
and at the time I didn't know what Islam
was about I had no clue anything about
it
and so I was just talking with them a
lot and getting to know them and like
why do they practice Islam why do they
believe it and what really got me is I
remember it was summertime because I
converted in July of 2022 and it was
summertime and so I didn't have school
so I was like up all night it was like
four in the morning I was like playing
video games and my friend texted me I'm
like why are you awake it's like four in
the morning he was like oh I'm praying
that's what really first got my
attention wait hold on rewind now so you
this is your friend what's his name uh
ibby ibby yeah so he's Muslim yeah and
you call him at what time I well I
didn't call him he texted me yeah
something along the lines he like
responded to something I texted him
earlier and he was like oh yeah my bad I
can't remember what we were talking
about he responded like five hours later
at four in the morning and so I'm awake
and I'm like why are you awake at 4 in
the morning and he was like oh I'm
praying fudge your prayers yeah that's
because we pray five times a day that's
the the early morning prayer now before
yeah
really caught my attention I was like
you're prank I was like bro it's four in
the morning why are you praying at four
in the morning you're like who does that
yeah it's a Christian that's like what
do you what like you know it's like
crazy to even think of that and so he
was like yeah bro I'm prank like this is
what Muslims do we got to pray five
times a day like okay bro I was like you
have fun doing that um but yeah that's
what really first initially caught my
attention is when he said he was praying
and it was like four in the morning and
so
then I started to do more research and I
was like I was just curious right I was
reading the Bible more every single day
and I was starting to pray to God like
three times a day like as a Christian I
was like God just guide me whoever you
are oh you know I've got no Coral with
you if you're Hindu if you're Buddhist
if you're you know from Islam if you're
Jewish like I have no core of what
religion you sent like I'll follow you
I'll worship you whatever and so I kept
praying it was like two months maybe
just constantly reading the Bible and my
faith in the Bible started to
deteriorate why I was just seeing so
many verses where it was like
like just vague hints where it's like
God is only one like not not even in
vague it's like clear like God is only
one there can be more and then the
Christians will say oh there's
occasional like vague ones where Jesus
like claims Divinity in a way but like
it didn't feel like that to me you know
it didn't really feel like that and so
my I don't know my faith just started to
deteriorate and I was watching so many
videos and whatnot and so finally I
searched up top 10 reasons why Jesus Is
God on YouTube and I was like okay this
is gonna be this is what's gonna I'm
gonna be good after this so I searched
it up watched the video it was some
Pastor it was like four minutes long and
it was just so like
there's nothing there there's no basis
there like nothing stuck with me he
wants you wanted something yeah
clear too yes revive your faith yeah
and then I was just scrolling I was like
man there's got to be some good video
here there's got to be something
and then I stumbled across your video as
I was scrolling top 10 reasons why Jesus
Is God your video came top 10 reasons
why Jesus is not God and it was with
um yusha Evans I think yes I think
um
and I watched that video and that like
almost
I don't even it almost like completely
destroyed my faith in Christianity like
from that point I was like man
I don't know I was like I don't know
what to do now like I was so like lost
at that point because I was like man
I've been doing this for 18 years of my
life I've been praying every day to
Jesus and doing this like
and I'm finding out like it's not true
like it's wrong the whole time and so I
was in a weird point in my life at that
point where I was like man I don't know
what to do so I started talking with my
friends some more and we were just
talking about Islam and I was like man I
just want to learn like tell me just
teach me everything I want to learn
because Christianity I'm seeing some
flaws right now you know
and so yeah it was just maybe two months
of just constant research and watching
debates and talking with my friends and
watching your videos and Zach or Nike
and like guys like this
and then it was just from that point on
I was like man I can't believe in
Christianity and so I just started to
learn solely about Islam from that point
I was like trying to understand it maybe
I want to practice it maybe I don't
and then finally July 14th I texted my
friend I haven't talked to him in seven
years maybe and I texted him I said bro
I want to take my shahada
he said bat tomorrow's Juma and at that
point I was like I don't know what Juma
was I was like okay I don't know what
that is but let's go so in July 15 2022
I went in and took my shahada and the
rest is history from there but you knew
now obviously what the testimony of
Faith was the shahada yeah right so you
knew that and uh everything made sense
to you yeah it was clear it was nothing
else to think of nothing wow no that's
probably let's talk about this prayer
like so you're doing this uh praying and
you're beseeching you're calling on God
like how was that so other people can
you know because people watch people who
are like let's say someone's out there
overweight or somebody who wants to get
healthy and he'll mimic someone who's
someone into physical fitness but now
someone wants to to you know they see
also that the contradictions they're
seeing that okay this Trinity thing
they're seeing this God dying for my sin
does it just doesn't make sense this is
not to disparage on anybody or any group
of people or anything but now it when
things just don't add up does it make
sense you go to get answers the answers
also don't make sense over here it's
making sense that God is one alone
worthy worship
so tell us like what was that like
you're making this prayer so you're just
praying to God directly alone are you
praying a mixture of Jesus and God like
what's the recipe that you're following
you know yeah
so to be honest with you there was like
no real recipe I was kind of just like
freestyling yeah I was I remember
I I put my head to the ground like how
we doing sajdah okay did you did you do
that because you saw Muslims no like
that no I just and the craziest part
every day in my house the way I face is
towards the Kaaba yeah that's exactly
where I put my head facing and I didn't
even know yeah that's how Jesus
prostrated and he went a little further
and fell on his face and prayed to God I
think that's in Matthew 26 39 where he
put his face on the ground so you did
that without anyone telling me to do
that yeah powerful wow and so I did that
and the crazy like I just realized that
now it's like I've been praying the past
few months in my house or whatever like
it's the same way facing the Kaaba I had
no clue at the time yeah but I just did
it and now technically this is just for
people to know education you don't you
didn't have to be facing yeah you just
coincidence I'm just saying it's like it
was just a weird coincidence yeah but
yeah the direction of Muslims face for
Humanity yes okay right so I did that
and then I just started to talk to God
and I was like I literally said like
word for word I said God whether you
Jesus whether you're Allah whether
you're Jewish god Hindu god I don't care
who you are just guide me and I'll
worship you that is deep man and then I
literally started to cry like at that
moment no but it was like tears of joy
like I wasn't sad it was like a weird
overwhelming feeling where I was like
feeling overwhelmed I don't even know
how to explain it was just
so weird in the moment but it was like a
good weird and so I just said you know I
don't care who you are just show me and
I'll worship you like it's not for me to
say no you have to be this no you have
to be that it's not for me to say that
wow that's deep I mean anyone watching
right now if they just contemplate think
over this because you're not see what
happens is when you give a definite when
you def you're not given a definite that
you're praying to Jesus you're like if
you are you're confused right so it
would be unjust if God didn't bring you
out of the confusion right you're like
if you're this you're that just guide me
I want to be guided right you aren't
like saying okay Jesus guide me or
Muhammad guy or no you're praying to the
Creator for guidance you're confused you
want to be unconfused and got unconfused
you and guide you to the truth to
submission to the Creator not the
creation Islam yeah
masha'allah this is amazing
alhamdulillah and for the people in the
Balkans who are watching us tuning in
now you're going to have a lot of people
who think um uh don't think outside the
box you were born here so you're a
little more open-minded but you still
know a little bit about you know the
things that go on can you talk about
that how the train you talk to me a
little bit give me a little bit of a
story you broke the news finally to um
your family because they were what they
were seeing you come home late yeah
you're going praying and I said like
you're doing something illegal let's
talk about that for a second yeah so I
was coming home late a few nights it was
like just before Ramadan and so you know
I was doing like voluntary prayers in
the Masjid with like friends and like
there was different events and stuff
going on so it was running until like 11
12 p.m a.m and so it was running a
little late so I was coming home later
like every day and I was like man I
don't know how I'm gonna do this in
Ramadan like especially with Kiam being
at like two it was like two at the
Martian I go to until three I was like
if I come home every the last 10 days of
Ramadan like every day at three they're
gonna think I'm like doing crazy things
you know so I came home and
my family was just like waiting for me
and they're like why are you coming home
so late every day and they thought I was
doing illegal stuff like or like
having a girlfriend like stuff like this
and I told him I was like no I'm just
hanging out with friends you know I
tried to just swirl my way past it but
they weren't really falling for it yeah
they're like no no this has been a
common thing lately like you're coming
home pretty late we don't know where
you're at
so I it was like just
Spurt of the moment I just said
I converted to Islam like just just I
didn't even know how to word it so I
just had to say it otherwise it would
have never came out yeah because
serbians it's like
a really bad connection with Islam like
they don't really like it yeah so the
whole time I was afraid how am I going
to tell my family how am I gonna tell my
parents how would they react
and so I kind of just up and said it
right and it's crazy because my dad this
the exact words he said to me I knew he
would say he said
this is the way I was born Orthodox
Christian he said this is the way I was
born I don't even care if it's wrong I'm
gonna die this way wow and you hear that
ignorance you hear this um in the Quran
Allah Allah got Almighty the Creator he
talks about this people blindly
following stubbornly really following
the way of their ancestors
you know just even though if it's not
the truth they just say this is it I was
born on it and I'm going to die on it
right that's not I mean that's not how
you were thinking huh no no for me
that's foolish no offense to anybody but
to me it's like I can't do that like
it's just ignorant and you don't want to
learn you don't have an open mind you
don't really care about the truth you
just want to do what benefits you what
what your ancestor did and so I couldn't
do that you you could have been brought
up worshiping a cow exactly right you're
gonna still worship the cows exactly eat
hamburgers yeah all right so yeah but
yeah so um how did they take that then
but you were breaking them in a little
bit right yeah so for for a few months
after I reverted I was sprinkling in
like a little things I was like ah this
doesn't make sense in the Bible or
you know what about when Jesus says here
that God is only one no no you know like
stuff like this and it was just months
and months maybe like four or five
months I was just sprinkling in little
hints like hey Islam is kind of nice
Christianity doesn't make sense you know
um but they didn't really think anything
of it it was more so like okay he's
curious because I've researched like
many religions like before Islam I was
researching Judaism uh Buddhism and I
was really into meditation and stuff
like that and so they didn't really
think anything of it right they were
like ah he'll he'll be all right you
know
but
when I finally did it it was there was
like no real anger it was more so just
like sadness like my family was just sad
they felt like betrayed they're like you
know this is how we were born how are
you gonna switch what you were born as
like you know and
that betrayal it kind of led to just
a sense of like they just felt
disconnected from me you know
but alhamdulillah like they've come
around a lot more I've it's only been
like a month and a half since I've told
them yeah but they've come around a lot
more yeah so they're taking it better
and better
um and my my grandma she hasn't spoke to
me since actually my girl you told her
also yeah my family told her yeah but so
quick yeah no it's like like this like
were you getting a lot of phone calls
then no no no I think it was more so
just like no one really wanted to talk
to him
kind of like that yeah but so my grandma
she hasn't talked to me since but my mom
I'll never forget what she told me and
that's why I love her no matter what
she said if my mom saw her her mom my
grandma if my mom was to disown you then
I would disown her and so I love my mom
so much like she wouldn't ever disown me
she's not happy with my decision
but if anyone else in the family would
disown me she would disown them and so I
love my mom so much and you know she
means a lot to me so she's coming around
the most I would say out of everyone and
that's that Mother's love you know and
you know by now I mean how much uh Islam
tells you to honor and respect your
parents and your mother yeah especially
the mother yeah so this is uh this is
just amazing man hearing this uh people
who are open-minded and you make this
prayer you're praying to God to guide
you and it's something that's so deep
yet so simple to do many people don't do
it
many people are not thinking purpose of
life people are dying we're not going to
be here for much longer I can die
tomorrow car accident disease cancer
whatever some can hit me and you never
know you never know your young age young
man and you're thinking about this and
then you're investigating you start
looking at all the different religions
and you're going against the odds
because people who know like myself I
know people are watching right now who
are from the Balkans in this area in
Bosnia Serbia you know that's like
something that's like you know ingrained
in the culture and people are like no if
you're a Serbian You Gotta Die Serbian
if you're crazy you die but you were
telling me there when you announced
online that you you accepted Islam that
there was a lot of other serbians yeah I
was actually kind of surprised that
we're also interested and like tell me
tell me tell us about this so I I made
like a a quick tick tock it was like why
converted to Islam it was like a minute
just like quick overview like brief you
know whatever whatever
and then like immediately blew up
because it's like a Serbian converting
to Islam it's like unheard of right so
it would like immediately blew up and so
I had a lot of messages from other
serbians yeah and it was like people
living in Belgrade in Belgrade yeah some
people living in Serbia they were
texting me like hey like I've been
really wanting to convert I don't know
what to do you know my family I'm like
man I understand trust me I understand
the family part especially because they
live in Serbia for me it's more
westernized they might be a little more
open to the idea but for them
man it's a lot more tough but I was so
surprised there's like a lot I had at
least like
four or five different people just like
within a week of first posting that
video of like people texting me from
Serbia or like one of them lives here
um but they're all like practicing Islam
in secret or some want to learn more
about Islam like none of them have told
their family yet and they don't know how
they will react and so I guess it was
kind of like
and lightning almost to be like I'm not
alone like there's a lot more people in
my situation a lot of them have it a lot
worse like I was complaining like man
what like why me like I gotta be put in
the situation like this is rough and
then I've seen all these people like
their stories are much worse and it made
me just be grateful I was like you know
what
I'm glad that at least it's not worse
because a lot of people you know they
have it tougher and it's more difficult
for them so have you been back to have
you visited I'm actually going in July
one of my family's getting married over
there so there's a lot of Muslims in
Belgrade isn't there there's something
there's a decent amount there's a decent
amount there's some massages there yeah
I think there's like two or three yeah
yeah not a lot but it's a start you know
it's a start maybe you should also try
to visit uh you got a lot of people in
uh like Novi pazar have you heard of it
yeah I've heard of it yeah yeah there's
a lot of a lot of Muslims there yeah
I'll try and visit you yeah and that's
um and how how have you been welcome now
how's the uh how's the the love been
shown towards you man it's
it's crazy the first
I would say the first two months of
converting to Islam
I'd say I got more love from the Muslims
than I did in 18 years of practicing
Christianity come on just in two months
for real why do you think that well I'm
not even joking like I'm serious
I I can't even explain your words
there's this Uncle
I love him to death he like comforted me
you thought you're calling it for the
people just you're calling them Uncle
this is
yeah he's in his older ages yeah so he's
at the Masjid every single day mashallah
every single day and so he seen me you
know just this white guy sitting in the
mushroom he's like hey can you speak
Arabic do you know how to read Arabic oh
my God no clue I have no clue so he told
me he was like okay I'll teach you and I
was like okay how much he's like no no
teach you for free I was like for free
okay like I'm not gonna say no yeah so
he spent like every single day with me
after either Assad or sometimes after
Maghrib he just spent every single day
with me for like three four months after
I first reverted like a month in maybe
and he taught me Arabic and now I could
read the Quran like perfectly it's been
like nine months and like he's a great
teacher and I'm very thankful for him
and there's been other people from the
Masjid other uncles also like a little
bit older like they've invited me to the
houses for iftar you know this during
Ramadan
and it's just like man I don't know you
guys and you're like doing everything
for me like I've gotten gifted like 20
throws like like I'm like running out of
space in my closet it's like yeah so
it's been super welcoming and that's the
thing that like really I respect so much
about Islam and Muslims I told one guy a
cafe you know what they were in Saudi
yeah they call itra in Saudi I think but
it's like the cafe where it's like long
or whatever I remember I told the Sheikh
I was like mashallah it looks so good I
really like it he took it off his head
he said here I was like
I was like I just mean it looks good but
I don't like I want you to give it to me
but he still went out and bought one for
me I was like oh man thank you but yeah
it's been nothing but love from everyone
like everyone I've never had anyone say
any smart remark to me or you know oh
you're a revert like why do you think
this nothing never it's been nothing but
love so the community been amazing you
think your parents if you invited them
would they come to the to the Masjid to
kind of sit to talk to learn to connect
with the community there I would hope so
come to dinner maybe maybe yeah I don't
know how comfortable they would be with
it you know
but it's it's an idea it's an idea yeah
maybe I'll float that out there and just
see like hey yeah you guys wanna
just see what I'm doing at least so you
know I'm not are they seeing the
positive change now are they seeing I
think so you know I don't know your past
before yeah usually like I've had guests
who come on and I remember stories uh
where people would tell me how their
parents their one one Iman Wesley he's a
good brother Puerto Rican brother I'll
never forget he shared the story with me
he said that uh when his father found
out that he accepted Islam when he at he
was asked I believe that's the thing
what happened he asked someone asked his
father how do you feel that your son
acceptance Islam so I can sleep at night
now
he can so you can imagine the kind of
Mischief he was in yeah and Islam got
him good made him good
luckily for me I actually I don't know
if it's luckily or unluckily but I was
like super religious even as a Christian
yeah so I never did I never smoked never
drink never did any drugs never hung out
with different girls and did all this
never party like none of this because
for me God has always been first so
there hasn't been like too much of a
change in that aspect but it's like me
going to pray every day like you know
I'm praying five times a day waking up
at four in the morning they're like man
like you know how is he doing it like it
yeah and all my friends are like bro you
know what I don't know how you do it
because all my friends they like to you
know hang out and party and do stuff and
like I don't know how you do it I'm like
I just
I don't know man like it's just it was
kind of engraved in me
I want to just touch upon when you
talked about you were being taught
Arabic because the Quran is in the
original in the Arabic The English is
the the translation and it's just like
if somebody for the serbians out there
or creation people who love say they
love Jesus the language he spoke was
Aramaic so imagine now if you had
anything original which we don't right
and you were seeing that obviously so
now if somebody let's say we did
hypothetically you'd be trying to say
the prayers in Aramaic so you're
learning the Aramaic doesn't mean now
that you're going to become Aramaic
right because you're trying to speak
that no you're just learning the
original language you're not you're
still Serbian you're not going to become
Arab exactly exactly right but you're a
Muslim sir no you're one who's submitted
to will of God and your nationality is
Serbian but you're a a Muslim one who
has submitted his will to the Creator
that's what a Muslim is and I think if
these things are pointed out with
education hopefully um and that's why
that was important I think that's in
this part of the world I also think
we've not that our right part educating
serbs and Creations and now out there
and have stuck on most a lot of this
nationalism forgot about sharing the
dean with them and we see what happens
so many serbs out there croatians when
they end up learning the truth they're
sincere like yourself yeah shahada time
yeah alhamdulillah so uh tell me uh so
you obviously you've learned now step by
step right you're still fresh and
everything have you so you've learned
the uh how to pray yeah the El Fatiha
the opening you've learned some surahs
yeah I'm I'm pretty deep in sort of I'm
actually today inshallah I'm gonna be
starting my hips
so so hold on you're starting your his
now today actually yeah yeah that's
that's for people share with the
audience now when you say hey what does
that mean okay yeah so hips it's
basically like a program kind of where
you
fully memorize the Quran like you fully
try to recite it perfectly every letter
every vowel everything you try to
memorize it perfectly right and so I
don't know how many there's like 10
million or something in the world right
now who our office where they memorize
the entire Quran and they know it from
the first ion to the last side right so
I'm starting today inshallah I was
actually supposed to start like two days
before Ramadan but then I was talking to
the guy who's gonna be I'm going to be
doing it with the chick and he was like
oh during Ramadan we're gonna take a
break and whatever and it's so much
that's a little bit farther from me it's
like 20 30 minute drive so it's like
okay I'll just start after Ramadan then
if you're gonna take the break anyway so
yeah so yeah inshallah today I'm going
to be starting yeah I was watching
something they had on BBC News you're
looking at one of the oldest fragments
of the Quran ever discovered it's
written on parchment most likely made
from sheep or goat skin and it's been
dated by experts as being more than 1300
years old and that makes it among the
earliest known fragments of the Quran
anywhere in the world and it's here in
the University of Birmingham
this remarkable document had been
resting on the Charles of the University
library for decades without anybody
realizing just how old it was until a
researcher decided to take a closer look
the pages were radiocarbon dated to no
later than the year 645 which means the
university has found one of the very
earliest known examples finding out that
we had one of the oldest fragments of
the Quran in the in the whole world was
fantastically exciting individually and
for the University of well as well I
mean we were expecting it to be early
but we we did not I think in our wildest
dreams expect that it would roughly
correlate to the lifespan of the Prophet
Muhammad which makes it an incredibly
early quranic fragment
the manuscript had been stored here in a
collection of Middle Eastern documents
brought to Birmingham in the 1920s
academics here say that this discovery
goes back to the earliest years of Islam
the person who actually wrote it may
well have known the prophet Muhammad he
would have seen him probably he would
maybe have heard him preach he may have
known him personally and that really is
quite a thought to conjure with
Birmingham has one of the country's
biggest Muslim communities and they have
welcomed having such a treasure in their
City when I saw these pages I was very
much moved and there were
50 years of joy and emotions in my eyes
and I am quite sure that even the people
from all over UK would come here to
Birmingham to
just have a glimpse of these Pages
people would love this
this is an exceptionally rare valuable
Discovery and the university says it
will be put on public display it is no
intention of letting these pages from
world history leave Birmingham Sean
Cochran BBC News
have you heard of it yeah so this is one
of the Miracles that we have look
imagine you have it just as it was
recited back then if someone picks it up
who's learning Arabic they'll be
reciting it and this Birmingham this
copy now now this has been verified they
can go check this up we have other
places in the world but this is now
something I think that's the oldest one
we have I I'm not sure if this oldest
might be but this is they're saying can
you imagine this is something that now
during the life of prophet Muhammad you
have this and now this is uh something
that you're inspiring now to memorize
also Serbian who accepts Islam
submission to the Creator at the
creation and now you're in a hiss
program trying to memorize the verbatim
word of God Almighty the Quran this is
amazing and that's one aspect of the
miracle look but the other one is that
like you like you were saying it's in
the hearts and Minds if you were just to
burn every copy of the Quran I mean this
is common knowledge you were to lock
them up in the safe in a vault get rid
of them you can bring some of these 10
million to memorize it today and in a
day the Quran would be completed same
exactly but you can't say that with
other books you cannot because you
wouldn't know which one is which which
one is the there's no original the
different versions people don't agree on
what's the you know connected to Jesus
what's not it's just like nothing's
authentic the Quran is authentic yeah
yeah that's also what like really drew
me towards yeah Islam yeah it's like the
fact that
the Quran first of all has no scientific
errors like there's many bold statements
in there many bold in fact in the Bible
it says that the moon has its own light
it's uh I believe it's a Psalm it's a
Psalm of David it's like Psalm or no
it's Proverbs Proverbs in the 20th
chapter roughly and it says that the sun
is its own light and the Moon is also a
smaller light in the Quran it actually
says that the sun is its own light and
the moon reflects the Sun's light which
scientifically we know is true yes so
the Bible got it wrong and a lot of
Christians they like to claim that
Muhammad peace be upon him like copied
the Bible this is a common claim yeah
but he didn't copy the errors then if he
did copy it like he
I don't even know how to say that like
he corrected the mistakes that are in
the Bible yeah if he was to copy it
right yeah so this idea it's like you
know it's a desperate it's like a straw
man you desperately try to strong man
yeah yeah you desperately try to like
knock the Quran any way you can and you
can't yeah and so yeah that's something
that really drew me toward the song is
the preservation of the Quran you hear
that a lot he copied it's like you just
said why don't you copy the errors like
somebody's copying from a peer next to
him and now he ends up identically he's
going to have this guy got to see he's
going to get a c right he takes
everything but no prob he's getting
everything 100 there's not he's taking
if he were to take the troops he would
take the errors too but there's no
errors right no it's a hundred percent
exactly you have some people you know
ignorant people who throw some things
out there you know what I mean but if
you go to the experts you you compare it
you'll be like there's there's no way
there's no way that this can come from
he can guess all these things that's
what really fascinated me and I was
talking to one of my guests uh about
this book this is a book here I don't
know if you read this book no it's a
gift there you go there's a give brief
Illustrated guy to understand Islam this
is one of the first books I read
actually further and that just you know
fascinated me had the prophecies it had
the signs you know a lot of science so
many things in there and then the basic
teachings of Islam really really
powerful that just did it for me you
know and then I'll definitely read it I
was like you I looked in all the
different religions and the tohi the
pure monotheism that's what really set
it off like you know you're only
worshiping God that's it you're not
worshiping Jesus or Muhammad or the
creation in any shape or form but you're
devoting all your prayer your sacrifice
everything for the one God for the
Creator Allah yeah
thank you for the book I'm definitely
yeah you're welcome I'm gonna put you on
a spot now so since you're in the hips
now so people can uh hear this this
opening prayer can you go ahead and
share it and recite it for us Bismillah
alhamdulillah
[Music]
so you were reciting the opening chapter
people go to the deanshow.com to get
this if they're in the United States
Canada
they can get this sent over to them and
you're reciting the opening it's the
opening of Fatiha and what you just said
in the name of God Allah The Compassion
the merciful all praises to Allah to God
Almighty lord of the worlds the most
compassionate the most merciful Master
of the day of judgment you alone we
worship you alone we seek help guide us
to the straight path the path of those
who you have blessed not those who you
are displeased with or those who go
astray that's the the meaning yeah
that's what we recite 17 times a day
minimum in in the prayer and anybody can
go ahead and make this prayer to go and
seek help uh anything else before we
conclude uh this is truly amazing story
this is really really inshallah this can
be a benefit to so many people so many
more serbs even croatians and others who
keep your identity your nationality but
seek the purpose of life and if you seek
the purpose of life and you do what you
did ask God to get you out of confusion
say guide me wherever you are guide me
you'll be led to where you're at today
so what else can you for the struggles
for people out there what advice would
you give them who are in that situation
they're like okay I'm brought up in this
way but they know they have this
trepidation in their heart they're
seeking to know purpose of life but
Islam all the negative stereotypes you
know all the junk that people throw at
it what are you having to think outside
the box okay
um
I can't really relate too much to other
religions like Hinduism Judaism and
Buddhism I can't really relate too much
to anyone who practices that but what I
will say for a lot of the Christians
right
I think the most important thing
a Jewish scribe came to Jesus and uh the
Gospel of Luke chapter 10 a Jewish
scribe came to him in verse 25 he asked
them how do I gain eternal life
Jesus responded do you know the law of
Moses
the man replied yes Jesus said how do
you read it this is the key how do you
read it Jesus didn't tell the Scribe how
do you interpret it how what are your
opinions on the law of Moses how do you
understand Allah no he said how do you
read it right clear you shouldn't throw
your own interpretations on in all this
the scribes unreplied and he like read
the law of Moses you know hero Israel
our Lord our God is one XYZ you know all
that and Jesus said
you have answered correctly
how do so I think that's the most
important part for all the Christians
when you read the Bible how do you read
it
like don't listen to what pastors tell
you no no this is what he means when he
says this this is what Jesus means when
he says this no no what does it actually
say right I think that's the most
important part because a lot of people
we have our own interpretations we have
our opinions and we try to force it on
yeah so you're born with the trinitarian
belief and then you try to force it on
every verse you could find you try to
just force it in there even if it
doesn't fit but no how do you read the
law of Moses where God says hero Israel
the Lord Our God the Lord is one
how do you read that the Lord is one one
you could try to force oh but this is
what it means it's a trinity no no
because Jesus said how do you read it he
didn't say how do you interpret it how
do you what's your opinion on it no no
so I think the most important thing for
all Christians
read the Bible
and how do you read it don't force a
trinitarian belief and don't force a
Unitarian belief just read it and just
see what happens and also I would
recommend just try reading the Quran
because that's where I started like when
I first started researching Islam I just
read the Quran the first I I think I
stopped at Imran I didn't get to any
side yet so I finished like the first
three or four chapters and then
that's when I was like ready to make my
decision like that's how eye-opening was
I didn't even have to read the whole
thing I was like no I'm ready so I would
say for all the Christians how do you
read the Bible don't put your own
interpretations on it don't you know
Force beliefs and make things fit where
it doesn't fit and just keep an open
mind just try and read the Quran if you
hate it after you read it okay then
there's nothing I can do but at least
try to read it and like ask questions be
open-minded don't be ignorant right
don't just oh no I was born this way I'm
gonna die this way like
that's I you know I can't really respect
that opinion where you just like so
close-minded you don't care
if you think the Quran is so wrong then
read it and find a error and there you
go if you go find one
you'll be the person who defeated Islam
people have been trying for 1400 years
everyone's failed so if you think you're
the guy who could do that you're the
woman who could do that then try it so I
just recommend all the Christians read
the Bible and do as Jesus says when he
says how do you read it don't force
beliefs on it and for everyone who has
already reverted to Islam
just take it slow a lot of people try to
rush things right and
people a lot of uncles they'll try to
like oh this is the proper so now this
is what you should be doing what I don't
do this do this pray this way they'll
try to tell you some things but just
take it slow you've experienced that
yeah a little bit a little bit they're
coming from good places they want to
help they're coming from good places but
it's like man it's been nine months
right this line was revealed over 23
years and you know
everyone didn't just start doing
everything in the first month Islam was
revealed and you know the Quran was
revealed like it didn't all just happen
in a month right so all the reverses
take it slow there's no rush
just learn the best you can and
you know one the most important thing go
to the mustard go to the mustard because
I've noticed
when I pray at home
there's like I don't feel as connected
I'm like I'm I'm focused I'm praying you
know but I don't feel as connected and
sometimes shaytan will whisper he's like
oh you could pray a little later you're
at home you got time it's also you got
two more hours and you can pray later
and then sometimes you'll like get busy
and miss it but if you go to the Masjid
when you're supposed to pray at the same
time every day you won't miss a prayer
and so I recommend just trying to go go
to the mission as much as possible and
their brothers and sisters who could
help you and give you guidance and
stuff along you know those lines where
they could help you grow a lot more you
know so I would say those are probably
the last three things
that I would end off on and that's solid
advice man because you you can also have
some bosnians who are born Muslim but
then they're not praying even and now
you're here Marco Marco yeah right who
accepts Islam and he's giving advice now
see this is the this is the beauty of
Islam now right now you're coming up and
reminding people praying the Masjid and
make your prayers because you have a lot
of Muslims you know and they're just I
think they inherited Islam but they're
not practicing prop you know they're not
even praying
so this should hopefully this inspires
them to be like man if he could do it
look at that you know come from this all
from this background accepts Islam comes
against his family and everything you
know and now he's over here reciting
Quran he's inspiring to be at half his
of Quran that's your intention how to be
of Quran inshallah may Allah make it
happen all right so inshallah probably
maybe I don't know how long some let's
say in two years we'll check up and have
you back on we'll know what it does get
you more motivation so we can next time
we get you back on uh you'll be half his
Quran you're one who's preserving the
Quran by heart and memory inshallah yes
absolutely okay my favorite Ayah in the
entire Quran I had to memorize it I was
making Dua one night it was before I
told my family I reverted Islam I was
making Dua
you know and you just name things that
you're afraid of or maybe you want or
Pleasures or you know you want a new car
I don't know whatever you want Jannah
like you want Heaven Paradise you know
you pray for different things and you
ask Allah for it so I was making Dua and
I'll never forget this day I was making
Dua it was like one or two in the
morning and I was like deeply distressed
it was like my fame I didn't know how
they were gonna react and I was just
listing different things I was afraid of
I literally said y'all I'm scared of
this what if my family rejects me what
if you know I'm not good enough what if
this I would I literally said I'm scared
of this I'm scared of this I'm scared of
this I'm scared of this I'm scared of
this I kept naming different things I
was afraid of
and I opened up the Quran
and literally it was like the third
verse it was like the third verse
I have 46.
do not be afraid
your Lord is with you and I am all
hearing and all saying and I think that
is the most important piece of advice
for all the reverts you might be afraid
right now but remember what Allah says
he is always with you and he sees
everything and he hears everything
I have 46. my favorite I probably
will die that would be my favorite
forever because
that point where I'm making Dua I'm
saying I'm scared of this I'm scared of
this I'm scared of this I open up the
Quran it's like the second or third Ayah
and it says do not be afraid I am with
you I am all hearing and I'll say and so
those are those signs houses you're over
there now praying to Allah help me with
this I'm scared of this you you just
happened to open up like five minutes
later I like finished
I'm just I just sat for a few minutes
just trying to like gather myself like I
was distressed like deeply distressed
and I was just like
let me just read the Quran like you know
and I I couldn't read Arabic at the time
I was like struggling I just knew a few
letters so I only read it in the English
but after I read it in English I was
like I have to memorize this so despite
I couldn't really read Arabic yet at
that point it was like recently after I
converted
uh I went and like heard someone
reciting on YouTube and I played it over
and over and over and over and over
until I could recite it myself and so
that's my favorite diet so all the
reverbs just remember Allah is with you
he's all seeing and all hearing so just
don't be afraid you'll be all right
inshallah hey Marco thank you very much
for sharing that this is really truly
inspirational inshallah this could be
more a motivation uh not just for the
the Muslims for the serbs for croatians
any human being out there who wants to
know their purpose they can inshallah
they can go to uh listen to your story
they get motivated go to the
deanshow.com right now you can get this
free on us give for me to you and if you
have some questions
1-800-662-4752 call right now don't be
shy
and uh inshallah you can start a new
journey in life and get all those
answers to the questions of why you've
been created why are you here where
you're going when you die everything is
lucidly clear and inshallah we can have
you back when you uh hopefully you
memorize you'll do it inshallah that's
one of the Miracles of the Quran and
you're uh May a Serbian who's now Muslim
who's inspiring to be a Hafiz of the
Quran thank you very much
thank you guys we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you
my dear brothers and sisters in Islam
listen if you want an opportunity to
support dawah to get this this is the
project for you to do that I'm saying to
you very clearly you know whether it's a
dollar or whether it's a million dollars
this is the project that you need to
support so we can have a template you
know for dawa and a community and we
need to ask Allah
duplicate this year 10 times All Over
America
center in Tampa Florida